no one gets really been able to crack
well I've had some suggestions as to
whether like why why is it that
sometimes yes there is another part
there will always be another part okay
or sometimes no it just can't be done no
matter where you start it's just
impossible okay when you have a look at
the information that you have at the
moment it it doesn't seem to take
everything into account example you've
got a whole bunch here which have the
same number of vertices but because they
are arranged differently in here huh
sometimes it's possible sometimes it's
not in the same way you've got sometimes
you know this is a different number of
vertices but they do work or odd and
even and it doesn't see too much more
level reason so here's what I'm what you
do I want you to click three more pieces
of information for me the first one is
we Canada the number of vertices but
there's something else we didn't count
something that's quite obviously edges
very good that seems like it'll be an
important piece of information because
that corresponds to bridges doesn't it
and we saw if the first example the
actual bridges of königsberg if you
change the number of bridges if you
really want you can make it work so this
seems like it would be important but
there's something else I want you to
look at okay when you have a look at the
vertices you should be able to see that
not all vertices are created equal some
of them are different and this is
getting at that original question of
like depending on your starting point
sometimes you'll find a path and
sometimes you work and you can't
depending on the points tied up
depending on which vertex okay so here's
how I'm gonna help you understand the
difference between as medicines depend
let's have a look at the first example
here okay
each vertex has what we call a degree
okay
so what is a degree the degree of our
vertex is how many edges come from that
vertex okay how many edges come from the
vertex
and this is what makes the vertices
different to each other okay so for
example let's have a look at one we'll
do it all together
okay this top better sukiya vertex how
many edges does it have two okay this
one in the bottom corner - Oh in fact
they all have two okay
two two two two okay have a look down
here number two right this one is the
same as the other diagram so it's - this
doesn't seems the other diagram as well
but then you've got two vertices that
are different and they are threes huh
when you come down through this one
right what's changed healthy versus how
many are how many edges come from each
of them well they're all like this this
one here right this is 3 this is 3 this
is 3 this is 3 you keep going what we're
looking for is are the vertices odd do
they have a odd number of edges coming
up like 3 5 or are they even okay so
when you work out these two numbers they
should add up to this number right
because that'll be your total number of
vertices after you go and do that then I
have a think about the fact that
everyone was able to find an Euler path
through two can you find it or the path
no matter where you start from do some
starting points work and substandard
points not work I'll let you have a
thick count them up fill up the table
and then see if you can find a pattern
off you guys let's have a look at this
now this is really interesting this is
really interesting because this this is
a very real world problem not just in
that it actually you know is something
that
benefit from all the time the fact that
this is improvement but we have to do
this you have to do this all the time in
real life you have to try and find
patterns where the pattern is not
obvious okay lots of data some of it's
completely irrelevant right some of it
doesn't matter a door has no impact on
the outcome right but other parts the
important post is sifting out what's
vital so let's have a look which other
ones which are problematic okay clearly
most of them seem to have boiler parts
they're only for you that don't which
ones it looks like it's gonna be this
one number three this one here number
four this one's got problem and then
we're fine until number nine so there's
the last one has an issues which by the
way is why I included it in the video in
the set so what is it what do check
three four and nine or these maps what
do these have in common
very good sir the problem is in this
column here it the vertices with odd
degree because you can see each one four
four and four these are issues these
cause problems for us okay and you could
I could actually keep on going I could
draw a more complicated diagrams for you
which have up which have more odd
vertices which should also cause
problems side by side question have a
look at the number of even vertices for
any given diagram can you see you can
have any number of even vertices but all
of the number of odd vertices they seem
to be even that's weird the odd vertices
they're always even question why are
they always even is there a way to
create a math such that it actually has
an odd number of odd vertices is that
possible if not why not
sigh question alright yeah then we have
to answer the question great we've
identified the pattern but we've not
explained the path seeing that it's
there is not the same as knowing why
there okay sir would anyone like to make
a suggestion
did anyone tell me why is this a problem
yeah okay excellent
all right let me repeat that idea in
case you didn't catch it because it is
vital and it seems like a very simple
thing but it's the real it's the crux
issue okay when you've got these bridges
right the whole way that this works is
that you have an entry bridge and you
have an exit bridge okay and so as long
as you have sufficient of these to be
able to get around to all of them you'll
be fine okay
for example if you have two bridges two
edges right one of them will be the
entry one of them will be the exit and
that's fine if you've got to diffuse God
forward it's also no problem right
because you enter by 2 and then you exit
by 2 everything's okay if they're even
which is why you can add any number of
even vertices you can add in this videos
you like and has no effect but when you
have an odd vertex that's when you're in
trouble okay because if I have say three
right degree three okay you entered by
one you exit by the other but you have
no way of coming back right because
you've got this this extra one and
you're like what do I do with this thing
okay have a look for example at this guy
right there or degree three okay so you
start I'll go another color you start up
here in the corner it doesn't matter
because this thing is completely
rotationally symmetrical okay so you go
down yeah right so I've entered here
I've exit in there I am to here I'm
exited there okay now this all looks
fine but when you go down this last one
you are totally stuck right this one
that's leftover vine cut in too bad you
can't exit by it it doesn't fit into
either of me
okay so you can have as many even ones
as you like you
stupid crazy really complicated diagram
and so long as you've got lots of these
it's all good right
but you can only have zero or two - okay
- is okay is - okay very good
okay so if you've got two let's have a
look at this guy here
right there's actually a way to not have
an Euler path watch suppose I start over
on this corner okay watch I'm gonna go
down here around I guess oh stuck right
maybe you thought oh it's because you
missed that middle one all right that's
fine let's just go back and do that one
get him out of the way first
okay down then across there down oh
there's always one left right and the
reason why this gets back to our
original modification of the cuttings no
problem
I started at an even vertex if started
even vertex you only got your entry your
exit and you'll never be able to get
back to that exit right you have to
start at what are the odd ones when we
began I think we started a deep which
was on it had three branches coming off
at three bridges but then when we tried
again we've started from a what if we
have it had I think it had four coming
off it right and that was the UM that
was the problem it's even you need to
stop okay stop the middle one you can
end it on one that's why I - or a case
or of course you can have none
nobody removed one remember it now
modify the situation yeah so right so
now we can come back to our original
table which look like that okay so now
work with me what's the degree of each
of the vertices you start a party on
three what's this on the right here
Tiger great what's this one three and
five hit oh god okay do one dumb you
can't work it out no matter where you
start from
it ends up really disastrous okay so
then he comes my my next question for
you okay
i manufactured all of these maps for you
okay
what's the simplest map you can make the
simplest map you can make that doesn't
have an Euler path now that you know the
way it works see if you can construct
your own network that can't actually be
it can't be solved see what you can do
see how simple you can make it I'll give
I'll start you up okay obviously if you
just got one vertex it's not much of a
map is it okay if you've got two
vertices no matter which ways you
connect them you'll always be able to
solve it why
because if I've only got two vertices
right the maximum number of odd vertices
I can have is two because obviously got
to max ever example if I make those look
at odd they're both on but that's okay
because one will be the start and one
will be the end well I'll let you try
and work out you can't have one vertex
you can't happen sooner than two simple
house in how complicated do you have to
go how few edges and how few vertices
can you make such that there's no by the
path possible okay I'll let you try that
out